ce week-end des journées du patrimoine
les sites historiques et d'autres plus
inattendus sont ouverts et gratuits dans
toute la france parmi les visites
possibles versailles le plus prestigieux
monument qui marque la grandeur de notre
pays du 16e au 18e siècle
cette année plusieurs aspects méconnus
de versailles sont mises à l'honneur
à commencer par la collection de
carrosses gérard dalmas daniel liste
théâtre de gloire du roi soleil
le château de versailles est aussi le
royaume du cheval et des carrosses de
l'ancien régime
limoges jusqu'à 2000 la révolution
rageuse a tout détruit sauf la
berlinette du premier dauphin l'aîné de
celui qui disparaîtra au temple
souvenirs touchant qui montrent leur
raffinement réservé à l'enfant royal
mort de tuberculose en 1789
en ce qui concerne le confort on voit
bien sûr qu'il y avait un marche pied de
cuir il y avait à l'intérieur une petite
cave qui permettait sans doute de mettre
la collation pour le prince il y avait
les vitres avec le ru le ruban de relève
vitres des jalousies des persiennes à la
vénitienne et tout l'ensemble était
garnie de cachemire et de passementerie
de soi clou de la somptueuse collection
ce monstre 7 tonnes nécessitant l'uchv
ou 12 là qu'est le carrosse du
couronnement de charles 10825 seule
voiture nous restant d'un sacre de
s'ouvre le n est l'aigle s'explique par
la rue dit lisa sion sous napoléon iii
cette voiture elle a été prévue par
louis xviii tout d'abord il lui 18 n'a
pas osé se faire sacrer ça paraissait
être trop provocateur et puis il est
mort
en revanche charles disent au contraire
dès qu'il a le discours de son avènement
annonce qu'il ne va se faire sacrer se
faire sacrer ça venir grenier avec la
monarchie de droit divin redonner à la
france un roi et alors il fallait que ce
soit un fast énorme pour faire oublier
toute l'épopée napoléonienne
un an avant les obsèques de louis xviii
avec cet énorme char funèbres qui a
resservi 899
le président félix faure mort de sa
belle mort champs-elysées 10 810
l'emportaient du mariage ne polluons
marie-louise 60 berline dont sept sont
ici louis-philippe surveillaient la
transformation du château en musée grâce
à cette chaise à porteurs c'est leur
fardeau était pesant les valets disait
qu'il menait une vie de bâton de chaise
quant aux chevaux des traîneaux il ruer
dans les brancards
les hivers étaient rigoureux pourtant la
course en amuser glissant dans les
allées enneigées organisant des courses
sur le grand canal figée par le froid du
c'est tout de même extraordinaire
d'avoir cette réunion parce qu'il en
reste peu dans le monde et de surcroît
cette raynaud là ont véritablement été
utilisé à versailles par les plus grands
personnages l'accord dont la marquise de
pompadour l'amante de louise 15 le
bien-aimé l'une des fidèles des joyeux
divertissement avec ces véhicules de
l'administration des menus plaisirs
l'époque des carrosses sur glace